but we all we all go and I hope that all
of you really think about what it is
that you want to leave Cameron Boyce was
one of the most kind-hearted and
talented souls in the world he
positively impacted the lives of
everyone he met and worked with
Cameron's Disney co-stars have taken to
the Internet to express their deepest
condolences and most treasured moments
here is how Cameron's Disney co-stars
are reacting to his untimely passing
Peyton lists Disney star Peyton lists
was one of Cameron voices closest
friends they met on the set of Jessie
back in 2011 and co-starred as siblings
for four years Peyton and Cameron dated
for a total of two years in 2012 but
remained close friends after their
breakup
Peyton posted a very touching tribute on
her Instagram page she spoke about how
Cameron's laugh was contagious and how
she could still hear it she talked about
how hopeful and full of love he was
Peyton listed the many ways Cameron
changed and influenced her life and
promised to tell her future children all
about him Peyton's touching posts is
extremely moving and sincere clearly
there was no one else in the world like
Cameron Skye Jackson much like Peyton's
Skye basically grew up alongside Cameron
on the set of Jessie she knew him
extremely well and has been posting some
very touching pictures in his honour
Skye took to Instagram to express her
extreme love and gratitude calling
Cameron God's best angel
Skye spoke about Cameron's hugs and how
they were the best she also explained
that she hadn't seen him in a couple of
months but should have hugged him harder
the last time they crossed paths to pay
tribute to Cameron's many talents Skye
has posted videos of Cameron performing
songs and dances on her timeline in
Skye's eyes Cameron was an amazing human
whom she loved with all her heart
Charles esten Charles esten was also
part of the Jessie caste
he played Cameron's father and grew very
close to his on-screen son during this
time
Charles posted a very moving piece about
Cameron explaining that their
relationship went much further back than
2011 Charles explained that he was
blasts know Cameron and his wonderful
family due to his children attending the
same elementary school as him Charles
posted a memory that paid tribute to
Cameron's extreme talents
according to Charles Cameron lit up the
stage during his very first talent show
and received a spirited standing ovation
Charles boasted about Cameron's kindness
humility effortless grace and great
sense of humor for Charles it was very
clear that Karen was meant to be a star
from day one
zendaya zendaya also took the time to
tweet about Cameron's shocking passing
both Sandhya and Cameron got their
starts on the Disney Channel and crossed
paths on the set of shake it up in 2011
sindhya commented on how absolutely
heartbreaking it was to hear that
Cameron had passed away in his sleep at
only 20 years old she also made sure to
send her love to his friends and family
Wendy Raquel Wendy had the honor of
playing Cameron's on-screen mother and
descendants
she played the role of Cruella De Vil
and despite her character having a bad
reputation Wendy and Cameron totally hit
it off behind the scenes
Wendy posted heartwarming words about
her dearest Cameron she opened up about
being a total loss for words
Wendy spoke about how every day is a
gift and that today she chooses to
celebrate cams life legacy and all the
love he brought into the world
Wendy's posts also went into detail
about Cameron's infectious smile and how
thankful she is that their lives
intersected Wendy posted the hashtag
rest well my son at the end of her
thoughtful message Gregg Sulkin
brag is a Disney Channel star who was
famous for playing Mason gray back on
Wizards of Waverly Place despite not
being co-stars Greg and Cameron were
longtime friends who were both a part of
the Disney family
Greg tweeted about how heartbroken and
lost for words he was he said that
Cameron was polite respond
full and always a class act Greg
mentioned that he had been wanting to
message Cameron a few weeks back asking
to be in each other's lives more this
just goes to show how important it is to
tell people how you feel about them
right away instead of letting the days
go by Kenny Ortega descendants director
Kenny Ortega had the pleasure of working
with Cameron for many years Cameron had
recently completed filming for d3 before
news of his untimely death spread across
the world Kenny took the time to post a
beautiful message about Cameron on
Instagram he sent his love light and
prayers to Cameron and his family Kenny
also spoke about all the love laughter
and compassion Cameron brought forth
with his presence he explains that
Cameron's talent wasn't measurable and
how his kindness and generosity were of
an overflowing nature Kenny said that he
will see Cameron in all things loving
and beautiful and that he will search
the stars for his light Kimmy's thoughts
are with Cameron's friends and family
members Chyna and McClain instead of
posting about Cameron's passing Chyna
and McClain posted a heartfelt video on
YouTube here we see the actress crying
over her best friend's sudden death she
explains that she chose to post the
video because she can't bear to look at
social media or read the headlines she's
having a hard time believing the news
but no matter how she feels she knows
that it's Cameron's family who is truly
hurting
China's wearing Cameron's hat during her
video when she explains that he'd
forgotten it in her room China ended her
heart-wrenching video by explaining that
despite can no longer being here she
knows that he's good and free booboo
Stewart dove Cameron and Sophia Carson
are taking their time to mourn before
posting on social media Cam's roommates
Karan Brar and Sophie Reynolds have also
remained silent during this devastating
news
they are undoubtedly mourning their
close friend and extending their love
and compassion to Cameron's family our
heart goes out to the boy's family and
everyone who was affected by Cameron's
passing rests in peace Cameron voice you
will forever be missed
adored and celebrated thank you all for
watching the things
[Music]